This guy cannot help but sound like the
absolute most maladjusted [music]
[__] weirdo going. No, but you don't
but you don't understand. The snarkers
say really mean things about Nick. They
say really mean things about Nick, so
why should he care?
>> The only solution to that is never
criticizing anybody ever again online
and living [music] in a padded cell
>> thinking this is like a full-blown slur.
Like this is actual racial abuse.
[music]
Stream about this guy. Talk about this
guy. pointing out how much of a
disgusting, dishonest [__] [__] he
is endlessly. I will do it week after
week. Okay, guys, let's get into this.
So, there's a Junk Draw Gaming video.
Okay, Junk Draw Gaming video here.
Obviously, this guy did some videos on
Willy Mac several months ago.
Now, he's been saying for ages he was
going to release this video, and my
understanding is he made like a bet with
the moderators of Aiden's Discord that
he would get banned if he didn't get it
out for New Year's. and they end up
pushing it right up to the line being
like, "Oh, I actually live in American
Samoa, so it's not New Year's yet. I
actually live on Baker Island, so it's
not New Year's yet. I actually haven't
failed it yet." And eventually gets it
out. And it's rushed and it's slow and
it doesn't snap like it could if you put
time into it. It's kind of annoying, but
hey, he got a video out, I guess. So,
let's take a look.
>> [music]
>> Throughout 2025, I've seen commentary
streamer and video essaist Nicholas
Dioro transition his content and
behavior into something totally
unrecognizable from how it was in years
past. I've seen the quality of his
content and analysis sharply decline as
he shies away from acknowledging any
criticism that is levied against him. In
this video, I want to break down some of
the ways that Nicholas has abandoned his
long-standing principles and show how he
is both willing to lie for his own
personal benefit and allow his friends
to lie with little to no push back. Good
start. Good intro.
>> My most prominent criticisms of Nick
come from his
>> could be snappier though. Once again, I
feel like this would have been so much
better if he just put, you know, some
time into the editing. Didn't just rush
it out. It's got 4.2K 2K views, easily
his best performing video. Imagine how
crazy it could have gone if it like was
edited properly.
>> Awful coverage of Ethan Klein. Nick is
in a complete 180 on his opinion of the
Kleins. He went from someone who would
proudly call Ela Klein horseface to
someone who makes pathetic graveling
sympathy posts for a plight as an
Israeli living in the United States.
>> The first wave of like uh commentary
channels that started to hate us.
>> Mhm.
>> They um they like to make a joke that I
look like a horse.
>> Joe Rogan should give Hila back her
meds. So you tweet this, right? And
somehow you trended over what now? What
was the story you trended over on the H3
Reddit?
>> Moses was being accused of sexual
assault.
>> Come on. Their thread was was [__]
on Nick for making fun of somebody's
looks. And here they are [__] on
somebody's looks.
>> And the best part is I don't even need
plastic surgery to fix mine.
>> Yeah. [snorts]
>> I just need like a diet and exercise.
You need a [__] They need to call a
surgeon to fix that [__] Oh ne
>> starts tweeting a picture of a horse and
Ethan adds his own context which is
driving him crazy and and it's funny
because it's like a 10,000 IQ play. Ela
goes, "Well, why can't he just call me a
horse?" The reason he can't call you a
horse is because you're [__]
>> So it feels like these clips just go on
too long as well. Like we're we are like
in a clip compilation now for a point
that Ray does not need that much that
much to it.
>> No, it doesn't work.
>> Like flag the tweet. No, BECAUSE YOU'LL
PROBABLY FLAG THE TWEET.
>> I don't think um using your [__]
platform to attempted to platform
someone is fair to me. And I'm an
[__] So if I want to tweet a a
[__] horse emoji, you can hate me for
it. You can think
>> I don't hate you for it. That's
>> No, but I I I brand myself as an
[__] I don't come on this internet
to be liked by people.
>> You're so cringe. I brand myself as an
[__] I don't come on this internet
to be liked by people. God, shut the
[__] You are such a [__] queer, bro.
God, that is so unbearable, man. Makes
my [__] skin crawl.
Dude, you can tell Aiden and Nick are
cut from the same cloth, man. Aiden and
Nick are cut from the same cloth.
Hardcore, bro.
>> Some really nasty stuff like calling he
a horse face and stuff.
>> I did do that.
>> That being said, water under the bridge,
but I'm just saying there was a reason.
>> Yeah, but he thought that I wouldn't um
forgive him or anything, but I actually
watch your content pretty regularly now.
>> I specifically I remember I'm like, why?
I don't think any of these I don't think
[music] like Hila Clyde I don't think
Ethan I don't think anyone's going to
forgive me for any of those comments or
anything like that
>> I think I really
>> and then she was watching the stream
>> I like I like the Oreo I got to say I
[music] got to admit it I'm a Dior Oreo
fan
>> so I had tweeted support for Hila Klein
is pivotal right now look at the quote
tweets all I did was tweet out like
support for
>> yeah also not going to lie I'm sick of
hearing Persona 5 background music in
all the [__] videos or is Persona 4 I
don't remember either way let's stop
let's leave it behind
No more Persona music and videos. Come
on now. We're done.
>> For Hila Klein, which I think is totally
fine. I think you're a complete [__]
loser if you have a problem with this
tweet. Um, go slop commentary YouTubers
are a waste of oxygen. Fat [__] crying
about the ugliest [__] getting
harassed. Uh, you know, the world has to
get nuked cuz fat [__] commentary
YouTubers uh think they deserve to live.
Support for the horse-faced Nazi settler
is pivotal right now. IDF sympathize.
There's not like a single positive
comment right now. Uh, I'm a Zionist
now. Support Eva Braun. She's Hitler's
Hitler's wife. Okay, that's a good one.
Uh, I'd [__] her, but that's as far as
my support goes. You don't have to like
her, but uh, we should never support a
Jew. [__] off, evil genocidal freak. Uh,
all you do is fuel anti-semitism. Jew.
No thanks, bro. Um, mumbly unrepentant
terrorist. [music] I made a voodoo doll
of Hila. I'm giving it hugs and kisses
to show.
>> This was a classic segment, by the way.
This is actually so such classic Nick. I
feel like Junk draws presenting this
badly as well. This is such a classic
Nick segment. This is like so funny and
it's just like not presented well. Dude,
I hate video essayists.
I [__] hate video essaists so [__]
much. either in the canros and they
spend six months doing Blender
animations and making like 30 different
videos that are going to be like one six
hour video. So get a grip, make your
video and put it out.
Junk draw wasting time going, "Oh, I've
got a job. I've got a job." When he's in
Discord like all night, every night not
doing [__] Liquid Sonic is the only one
who like gets out consistent halfdecent
content.
It's crazy. It's genuinely crazy.
>> She's Hitler's Hitler's wife. Okay,
that's a good one. Uh, I'd [__] her, but
that's as far as my support goes. You
don't have to like her, but uh, we
should never support a Jew. [__] off,
evil genocidal freak. Uh, all you do is
fuel anti-semitism. Jew. No thanks, bro.
Um, mumbly unrepentant terrorist. I made
a voodoo doll of Hila. I'm giving it
hugs and kisses to show my support. Uh,
no, you're a she's a Jew. Hope she dies
a horrible death. Um, you mean the
raider of Ramla, which was a I mean,
this is just like [laughter] we need the
people to deal with her. Only nwords and
fslers care about this. Yeah, I don't
know.
Nick was one of Ethan Klein's biggest
critics back in 2020. He put out a
multi-part video series strongly
criticizing Ethan for his unhinged
behavior. But now Nick will stop at
nothing to defend Ethan. And we all have
to pretend that Ethan has changed in
some tremendous way. This leads me to
question if 2025 Ethan is really that
different from 2020 Ethan. Let's look at
some of the main criticisms that Nick
used against Ethan in his 2020 video
series. Nick criticized Ethan heavily
for using Etica's death as a way to
attack Keemstar in 2020.
>> Why does this dude's legacy need to be
subjected to this? Why does this?
>> So, I've heard some people say that they
feel like Nick was more dishonest back
when this happened about this than he is
now, if you know what I mean. Like, some
people say that he was just sweeping for
Keemstar here and that Keemstar was, you
know, did kind of have in a way blood on
his hands with the Etica stuff. Now, I
don't know the truth of that because I
didn't follow any of that gay [__]
but my understanding is Keemstar was
definitely um not not behaving well.
dude's tragic suicide need to be
weaponized and debated on a year later
in YouTube drama exposed video. This
just feels like a copout because he's
gone. He's unable to speak for himself.
Etekica is unable to interject and let
people know what he was feeling or pick
a side. It's an allegation that H3H3
felt comfortable to walk right up to the
door with because Etekica is not here to
tell him that's not true and nobody
knows exactly what was going through
Etekica's mind
>> to this day. So yeah, I think that's a
broadly a good point though regardless
of whatever you say about you know how
Keemstar behaved to lay the blame solely
at someone someone specific's feet
without like you know some real evidence
to support that is is crazy you know so
I think regardless even if you feel like
maybe he was sweeping for sweeping for
Keto sorry back then I felt the point
stands really
>> Ethan still regularly engages in this
behavior back in June Michaela Reigns
the founder of the Save a Fox wildlife
initiative took her own life due to a
combination of mental health issues and
criticism that she received both online
and in real life regarding the way she
ran her animal sanctuary. Most of the
online harassment she received was from
Kiwi Farms, Tumblr, and a very inactive
Snark subreddit, which only had 19 posts
in total at the time of her death. Ethan
Klein very quickly decided to make this
woman's suicide about himself, claiming
that her Snark subreddit was the
deciding factor in her death and
comparing it to his own Snark subreddit,
claiming that their end goal is to get
him to kill himself. In reality,
Michaela's death had very little, if
anything, to do with her tiny snark
subreddit and likely had much more to do
with the harassment and criticism that
she received from other her life in
combination with her mental health
struggles. This didn't stop Ethan from
turning the spotlight on himself in an
effort to remove criticism of himself
from the internet. It would seem like
Dioro doesn't personally agree with the
assessment that Michaela Snark subreddit
was the reason she killed herself.
>> So, yeah. Yeah, a girl save a fox killed
herself from
>> [music]
>> uh on a snark sub. It is crazy. And yet,
>> yeah, I just I completely disagree with
this. Reddit does nothing and there is
no account.
>> But despite boldly disagreeing with
Ethan on this over 6 months later, Nick
Stills never addressed Ethan weaponizing
this woman's death to bolster his
campaign to remove his detractor base
from the internet. Ethan Klein even made
Charlie Kirk's death about himself.
Within hours of Kirk's shooting, Ethan
was posting Instagram stories blaming
websites like Twitch for the shooting
and saying that he feels unsafe due to
Mike from PA of all people. Ethan will
dig up any corpse.
>> So, I feel like, you know, I obviously
totally agree with all the saber fox
[__] like completely.
Um, the thing is that Nick has like made
these he makes like these [__]
off-hand comments like, "Yeah, I guess
it's bad. I guess it's bad." And he
thinks that's like covering the topic
and saying he disagrees with Ethan when
it's not. Obviously, it's more than
just, you know,
Nick says, this is what Nick wants to
say to people, okay? Nick wants to say,
"The only reason anyone's upset is
because um I make money covering topics
they don't like me covering. That's what
this [__] fat [__] idiot wants to
lie and say, but it's how he covers
those topics." Just going That's bad. I
guess that's not actually covering that
topic honestly, is it? Because you know,
and the whole audience knows and anyone
with any [__] sense knows if the
enemy quote unquote did that same
transgression,
you'd be going a million times harder.
It would be the focus of the stream that
day. But it's not. It's a quick, oh,
that's bad, I guess.
And then you move on because you don't
want to make a big deal out of it
because you're you're on that team
because you're [__] compromised as
[__] And everyone can see this. You go
back, I'm pretty sure. Isn't this what
Alex Gekkmo turned on Nick over? Isn't
this basically what Alex Gekmo turned on
Nick over was that when the Saber Fox
[__] stuff happened, it was like so
blatant and he said he put out some
tweet being like, I'm going to see how
[laughter]
I agree with him. I'm going to see how
Nick recovers this. And then Nick goes
live that day and either doesn't speak
about it or like glosses over it and
he's like, "Okay, yeah, [__] this guy."
Cuz it is just so obvious. is the most
transparent obvious [__] in the
world that if Assan was sitting there
weaponizing like a still warm body.
That would be topic of the day that day
that would be number one headliner on
the on the Nick Dioro FFWN
stream, you know. So it was the reason
she killed herself.
>> So yeah. Yeah. A girl save a fox killed
herself from uh [music] on a snark sub.
It is crazy. And yet
>> yeah I just I completely disagree with
this. Reddit does nothing and there is
no account.
>> But despite boldly disagreeing with
Ethan on this over 6 months later, he
never addressed Ethan weaponizing this
woman's death to bolster his campaign to
remove his detractor base from the
internet. Ethan Klein even made Charlie
Kirk's death about himself. Within hours
of Kirk's shooting, Ethan was posting
Instagram stories blaming websites like
Twitch for the shooting and saying that
he feels unsafe due to Mike from PA of
all people. Ethan will dig up any corpse
that he can and make anyone's death
about himself to get
>> Mike from PA is doing stochcastic
violence. He's doing stocastic violence.
He says Jews are evil. The
>> upper hand over his enemies in 2020 was
so critical of this behavior that he
included
>> I'm getting stocastic violence to death
by Mike from PA
>> etica tribute in his video. But now he
won't even address Ethan's participation
in this same behavior. Nick also heavily
and rightfully criticized Ethan for
starting a trend of going after an enemy
sponsors online. In 2020, Ethan went
after Keemstar's Geuel sponsorship and
ended up getting him dropped from the
company. In retaliation, Ethan claimed
to have lost about 80% of his podcast
sponsors. Nick said that he didn't
support the sponsor war, but felt no
sympathy for Ethan starting.
>> He's apparently lost 80% of his own
sponsors for the H3 podcast. Now, to be
clear, nobody is sure if this is
partially due to co or 100% in relation
to his attacks on channel sponsors in
May, but regardless, it's a clear case
of karma rearing its head. I'm not one
to celebrate money being pulled out of a
creator's pockets, but I also don't
really have sympathy or empathy for
those who have made the statements Ethan
has made and continues to make. Ethan
still engages in this behavior except
today he goes after Twitch's sponsors
directly.
>> So anyway, cap shout out to Cap Capcom,
Chevron, and Samsung who are proudly
displaced on the backdrop of this.
>> So yeah, the whole time Ethan's doing
all these anti-sponsor campaigns.
You're supposed to give a [__] that
pro Pal people don't want to buy Teddy
Fresh anymore. Pro Pal people don't want
to pretend his [__] wife's makeup is
any good. in which um Arab to Israeli
hummus brand I perceive as Zionist or
Jew Jew basically
um
Arab to Jew tier list being enjoyed.
>> Also another point about how terrible
Junk Draw Gaming's video is here. He
does not have the clip of Nicholas Dioro
saying that Habibi is a slur on part for
with the nword for Arabs.
He doesn't have any of those clips.
Totally absent
because he wanted to make some gay bet
about a [__] Discord and rush this
video out in a few hours.
>> In front of Chevron, Capcom, and Sabong
proudly sponsor.
>> Yes, she said that. Yes.
>> In collaboration with Twitch. Um,
[__] awesome.
>> I would argue that this is much worse
because targeting these website sponsors
could impact
>> Kathy, you're being totally compromised.
Aiden did not ruin it. It's not Aiden
that ruined it. Junk Draw ruined it.
It's Junk Draw's video. He made the
[__] commitment about getting banned
from the Discord and all this [__]
>> More innocent creators who just so
happen to use the website and have
nothing to do with the perceived
anti-semitism that Ethan is saying. Now,
you would assume that Nicholas, who
previously was so principally opposed to
Ethan starting a sponsor war against
Keem, would be pretty appalled by this.
Well, in reality, he said that Ethan's
actions were probably wrong, but
ultimately excused them because of the
Arab to Jew tier list. I'm sorry, dude.
You can get mad at Dan. You can get mad
at Ethan. And most of it's justified, I
guess, about going after sponsors, but
don't forget that Twitch had an Arab to
Jew tier list. I'm sorry, but there's
never been anything like this. This
isn't comparable to PewDiePie on
YouTube. Twitch let them host an Arab to
Jew tier list in front of five [__]
sponsors on the wall at their own
convention and then had to get bullied
by social media into [__] enforcing
their own [__] terms of service. He
provided no commentary about the
potential blowback that starting an ad
apocalypse level sponsor war against
Twitch could cause for innocent creators
and actually quickly segueed into a
segment about Mia Khalifa,
>> Chevron, Capcom, and Samsung.
Do you know
that there is an Arab to Jew tier list
happening in front?
>> It is. It literally is an Arab to Jew
[__] tier list,
dude. Could you imagine? It's like hard
R to honky to your left.
>> Wait, [laughter]
>> he's got part of it there. There is more
to this though. There is more to this.
There is way more. Dude, do I have it
anywhere?
>> [__] One second. Let me ask around. Let
me see if I can get this. Let me see if
I can get this.
>> Dude, I I I need to see this. This needs
to be a real thing.
>> I watch this clip and I'm like, what the
[__] am I actually watching? This is
This is mad. I need to say something.
>> This is legitimately a totally
reasonable reaction to the [__] you're
seeing. People are saying this is
Ethan's crash out. Have you read any of
the Reddit posts or seen any of the
tweets from this community? If you're
insulated in like my sector or you're
looking at any of his stuff, go to the
Hassan [__] subreddit and just do a
scroll even today. You're not too late.
You'll see a bunch of people acting like
this is their literal personal 9/11.
>> Um, so they are very in touch with the
Jewish identity. Um, so we're gonna have
to ask them.
>> Wait, what?
>> What is Bunny King?
>> No way.
>> Who is Bunty King?
>> No [__] way, dude.
>> Holy [__] Chat, pull this up for a
second. We'll get there. We'll get to
that. I got to pull up Mia Khalifa. All
right, speaking of professional tits on
a screen, pull up [__] Mia Khalifa
right now. Mrs. PTSD from porn. This is
one instance of a trend where Nick
refuses to engage with criticism that he
knows he cannot defend. He even admits
that Ethan is mostly wrong in his call
out of sponsors. But still,
>> I think Jung has the clip about
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think he's got the one
about the denim's chat edit, isn't he?
Yeah.
>> Searches for a way to downplay any
potential criticisms due to the
perceived anti-semitism from Twitch. A
big point of contention in Nick's
second.
>> Yeah. Literally anytime when Nick talks
about porn or sex or any [__] like that,
it sounds like the creepiest [__] ever,
this guy cannot help but sound like the
absolute most maladjusted [__] weirdo
going whenever these topics come up.
It's just like
ugly ugly bastard vibes. Do you know
what I mean?
They cast they cast in Dioro as the
[__] still life model for ugly
bastard dojans.
They record they're recording his voice
lines for the ugly bastard hentai games.
2020 video on Ethan was that Ethan
platformed and legitimized the creator
Bitbrong Returns. Britong was a serial
to platformer doxer swatter and someone
who would routinely fill Discord servers
and DMs with illegal material. While I
do believe that BBong Returns is a much
more detestable online figure for doing
things like spamming Aiden Underground
in Auggie RFC's DMs with illegal
material, a comparison can be made in
the sense that Ethan still works with
unhinged degenerates like Dan Saltman.
Dan Saltman is a doxer, liar, and a
platformer who will stop at nothing to
get Hassan to platform from Twitch.
>> So apparent, you know, this Brit Bond
guy is like a big, you know, the big
boogeyman for these guys. So apparently
like daring to compare anyone to that
guy is like, wow, how could you dare?
How could you possibly dare ever compare
these things? Obviously, you know, the
point is they're both doxers who are
doing [__] that's totally out of the
[__] rule book and you should be
against it and you shouldn't be okay
with him [__] propping them up as an
attack dog. That's the point.
>> And Clancy fired as their CEO. He's
doxed Hassan's moderators.
>> There's one of Hassan's moderators, the
guy named Comrade Lamb, and uh he's been
on his account
calling me a pedophile.
Um, and I just I did a
subpoena and got his information, his
full information. I'm gonna,
>> you know, it was quick, surprisingly.
>> Wait, really? You could just do that?
>> Yep.
>> Stop. No,
>> that's lit.
>> No, don't do that [__] on my stream.
>> Gone after Twitch's sponsors to try to
start his own ad apocalypse and gone as
far as to contact the mainstream media
and politicians in his crusade. Ethan
proudly displays a redact.dev dev
sponsorship, which is Dan's company, on
all of his live streams and is in
constant communication with Dan behind
the scenes. Ethan doesn't just platform
these degenerates. He now takes
sponsorship money and endorses these
people. Again, I'm not saying that Dan
is as bad as Bripbong, but any person
who is principally opposed to Ethan
legitimizing
>> spineless freak JTO, I watched the
works. Turns off, dude. What else he
supposed to do? What else he supposed to
do?
>> Bong should also be opposed to
collaborating with Dan, but Dioro
couldn't care less and has even
platformed Dan himself at times. Nick,
instead of condemning Ethan for working
with Dan, will routinely use him as a
scapegoat to write off many of Ethan
Klein's criticisms. If Ethan says
anything that is blatantly false or
accuses his son of something out of
context, it's always Dan's fault for
feeding him misinformation. Ethan can
never just be wrong or malicious in his
framing of his enemies. There's also the
elephant in the room of Ethan Klein's
malicious lawsuits. It's no secret
principally opposed to these law.
>> Thank you for the membership. Thank you.
>> I find it ridiculous that any so-called
commentator would think of supporting
them. These lawsuits are built upon a
lie that Ethan needs to defend his
copyright and are being used as a
political weapon to silence Ethan's
critics. And in the case of the H3 Snark
moderators, these lawsuits are being
used as an attempt to dox their private
identities in an attempt to scare away
future criticism. Ethan has expressly
stated that he wants to reveal the
identities of the Snark moderators to
their families, schools, and jobs.
Essentially doxing them and
participating in life ruination. His
orbiters will use
>> No, but you but you don't understand.
The snarkers say really mean things
about Nick. They say really mean things
about Nick. So watch ta
>> Paul as a way to deflect away from this
unhinged behavior as if it is some sort
of get out of jail free card that allows
Ethan to do literally whatever he wants
forever. Ethan has even outright lied in
his legal filings incorrectly claiming
that one of the snark users was a mod
that was collaborating with Denims to
steal his copyright. In reality, this
was just a regular subreddit user who
sent Denims a DM expressing that she
should stream a reaction to the content
nuke to avoid giving Ethan views. She
never even responded to this message.
Literally anyone can message Denims on
Twitter, Instagram, her Twitch chat. And
I guess if you really want to spend $20,
you can message her on Only Fans or
Fansley. There's no guarantee that she
will respond to any of these messages,
but anyone can try to get in contact
with her. Again, this is an instance of
Nicholas blatantly downplaying and not
engaging with criticism against Ethan
Klein. He claimed that he would look
into this if it was a lie, but then
never ended up following up.
>> I think it's the Dan Saltman tweet is
the important one. I don't know if this
is actually a moderator. It seems like
preliminary reporting is, yeah, this is
an H3 Snark moderator. I don't know who
this Dardis guy is. I don't know how
they got that information.
>> I just saw careful.
>> Maybe look into it. We thought about
looking into it. We fact checking
looking into it.
>> The shout out putting any effort in
behind this.
>> I feel like if this is real like not
that like
if it's real because it's from the
lawsuit. If this is actually a moderator
and that's actually the Discord tied to
the moderator, this is really bad for
them. This would be really bad for them.
This is like
>> wow. If it was
>> either absolutely nothing or a complete
and total nuke.
>> I if that if that's a Reddit moderator
that's if that's a look into that.
>> This is absolutely [__] worst case
scenario for Denim's mm probably.
Like that is actually [__] crazy.
They're completely diluted in their
little bubble. I've heard privately from
people and I'm not going to name any
names. They're they're skeptical about
this. So I'm proceeding with caution.
But I mean that's [__] that act would
be [__] crazy if it turns out to be
fully accurate.
>> These lawsuits were never really about
copyright. Even Nicholas has openly
admitted this on Discord. Nick has
outright stated that it would be
delusional to think that these lawsuits
are exclusively about protecting
copyright. But he still has no problem
supporting Ethan's blatant lies that he
is simply trying to save the YouTube
space from content thief reactors that
all just so happen to provide harsh
criticism of his political takes on the
Israel and Palestine situation. Nick has
perfectly fallen in line with Ethan's
attempt to brand his detractor base as
some kind of unique evil when they are
pretty standard alogs that you can find
in any large online community.
Seriously, has the treatment that Ethan
receives any worse than other locals
like Wings of Redemption, Boogie, Ethan,
Ralph, or Christian Chan? Ethan himself
will even use subreddits like Trisha Pis
Snark and Nick basically runs a Snark
community against people like Idubbbz
and Bolex. In reality, if Ethan would
just disengage and stop fighting with
his detractor base, so many of his
problems would go away. Ethan is a
nearly 40-year-old multi-millionaire who
routinely throws himself into the line
of fire by giving his takes on Israel. I
don't feel any sympathy for a
middle-aged man constantly putting
himself and his family in this position
simply due to the fact that he's
incapable of disengaging. Here's Dioro
describing this exact sentiment about
tipster.
>> Are are these types the ones that are uh
>> uh yeah, I am I am sort of feeling that
way about local. I feel like it's kind
of run its course when I saw,
you know, 500 different localal live
local live gold local granny local
[__] basement local shed. It's like
holy [__] Let's It's done. It's dead.
It's over.
It's over. And like all those Kiwi not
Kiwi, Kiwi, what's his name? Kiwi tapes.
And all those guys [__] suck.
They suck.
We don't We're done with the low cow
[__] Just, you know, it's not even that
interesting. Like there are people who
have freakouts and are like interesting
and funny,
but we're done with the um you know,
we're done with Christian Chance. Okay,
we're really done with Christian Chance.
>> Um they don't belong online chat. the
tipsters, the Jalins, the Flamos,
the people who have the LOL cow gene,
the people who constantly dive directly
into the the spotlight and just get
farmed for weeks and weeks.
>> How do people have this much energy,
man? How do people like scream like this
advis
some advice?
>> You could give Flamco a fireside chat
>> about tipster. just let it go.
But they're never going to, okay? They
don't they don't they can't you can't
help them. You can't help them because
they're grown [__] children. But for
people like Tipster and Flamco who are
already in their 30s, approaching their
40s, um, at some point you just start
not feeling bad anymore.
>> If he had any consistency, he would feel
the same way about Ethan, that he has
the low cow gene and is old enough to
know better than to keep poking the
bear. But with Ethan, we have to keep
playing defense because of a CPS call
that happened a year ago. A call that
never would have happened if Ethan had
not revealed very personal information
about his children's health online. No
self-described commentary creator should
be supportive in any way of Ethan's
blatant attacks on free speech. Ethan
fans and orbiters like Nick claim that
he is only going after people who were
malicious in their attempt to infringe
on his copyright. That falls flat when
he has previously described XQC as
someone who deliberately steals content
with his lazy reactions.
>> Take it back in. No, you're you still
are a content thief in my opinion.
>> Take it back.
>> No, you Why would I take it back?
>> Because if you're going to reel it back,
>> another thing that's probably worth
going over here if you're actually going
to argue these points about the lawsuit
is the fact those statements don't all
really line up with the idea of stated
malicious intent. Like Denim just says,
"Oh yeah, I'm going to be live to
someone asking about being able to watch
it there instead of Ethan's."
>> I
>> No, I just said that wasn't a good
analytical point. I still think you're a
content thief.
>> Turn up a little. This would imply that
XQC is also malicious. And since he
essentially free booted Ethan's entire
video, wouldn't that qualify him for a
lawsuit as well? It's so obvious that
Ethan is just weaponizing the legal
system to force apologetic statements
out of his online enemies. These
lawsuits are fundamentally built on
lies, both regarding the legal reasons
for filing and the stated purpose behind
targeting individual creators. Ethan
already settled with Caseyron and made
her give some strange ISIS beheading
style apology that he lied about and
said was genuine. I also think he's
quite likely to win against Frogan as
she also did a poor job reacting to his
content nuke. Denu's reaction on the
other hand
>> is it's great hearing peace go phrasing.
You know, I love hearing peace go
phrasing. That's showing competence.
Okay, that's the editing might suck. It
might be a clip compilation that's slow
as [__] and rushed. The music might be
trit choices from Persona,
but at least Jung Dro is smart enough to
steal Pisco's phrasing for his for his
points.
That's competence. That's competence.
Shows both the hypocrisy of Nick and the
lies that he's willing to tell on
Ethan's behalf. Dennis provided a
substantially better reaction than both
Caseyron and Froggen. She even had a
longer reaction to the content nuke than
Nicholas Durio himself. Dennis more than
doubled the runtime of the video with
her reaction and provided commentary
throughout. This is the same standard
that was used to defend Chudlo Logic
against Dark Viper AU when he filed a
copyright strike for Chud's reaction to
his video. The community, Nick included,
argued that since Chud more than doubled
the runtime of the original video with
critical commentary, his video was not a
market replacement and was fair use.
When Denims clears these same markers,
the goalpost shifts and a new standard
is created that all of her commentary
must be perfectly factual and relevant
to the content that she's reacting to.
Nick says that her reaction was
irrelevant and filled with non-related
commentary and moments of reminiscing
about past dramas. That means I added
120% [music] of the run time in
commentary on average every 30 seconds
to add 30 seconds.
>> Is Aiden going live? We getting an Aiden
stream,
>> dude.
>> Of commentary. Now, I'm not facteing
this. I'm going to assume that she's
telling the truth here.
>> I remember watching her video on my
stream. You can actually watch my
reaction to Denims cuz I did react to
her viewing of it and it was literally
damage control. She'll go on a random
tangent about something that has nothing
to do with the video or she'll hear
Ethan say a sentence and then go on like
remember this one time kind of things.
So despite that she's saying that I
don't think that she added 130 minutes
of actual content to it as much.
>> Yeah, he was literally being and he was
being such a mopy queer about streaming
on Paris earlier as well. I assume you
guys heard that where he was being just
like
everything sucks and I hate the
audience. Everything sucks. I hate the
audience. It's very easy saying that by
the way.
Yes. Obviously the audience at large is
[__] Like everyone understands
this. Everyone understands that there's
a bunch of people in chat. They're
probably total [__] losers and
they're total skits and can't hang. Yes,
we we all know those people. Yes, some
people are fine obviously, but they're
the minority. So, it's like a total cope
to pretend that that's why you suddenly
are pissed off with it. He's just like
mad that every time he goes live people
are just like,
"We're sick of Leo Convoy. Stop talking
about [__] Leo Convoy just because
you got grudge over your girlfriend.
Stop talking about gay ACC [__] Do
something interesting, you know? That's
what he's mad about. He's mad that the
the vibe changed on him that before
everyone was like loving it and now he's
doing like [__] AIDS people don't.
>> So, she might have paused and talk or
thanked somebody for something.
This is hilarious if you've ever watched
a Nicholas Dioro reaction as his streams
are full of irrelevant cutaways to MCU
references and memories of past dramas.
I found several instances of this when
looking for clips for this video.
>> That sounds like some [__] in Family
Guy. Peter Griffin's like, "Yeah."
>> Oh, yeah. So, dude, here here's the uh
great point here. Nick Dioro claiming
that making irrelevant comments about
Family Guy isn't good enough.
>> Minutes of actual content to it as much
as she might have paused and talked to
chat or thanked somebody for something.
This is hilarious if you've ever watched
a Nicholas Dioro reaction as his streams
are full of irrelevant cutaways to MCU
references and memories of past dramas.
I found several instances of this when
looking for clips for this video.
>> What's the deal?
>> That sounds like some [__] in Family
Guy. Peter Griffin's like, "Yeah, it was
Pearl Harbor. That's why uh that's why I
come out here and I fight the way that I
do every single time." And they want
Lois Griffin. It seems like you've been
winning a lot tonight. What What is your
driving factor? Oh, Peta already told
you this story about Pearl Harbor,
right? Okay. Um, well, I guess for me
[laughter]
>> I I think the ego is kind of crazy.
>> Do you remember when you'd be like, "Oh,
what what what are they talking about
here?" And then EDP would be like,
"Chris Tyson, Chris Tyson's looking at
Lollipop. We need a bigger we need a
better brand of influencers." And it's
like, "Dude, you're a pedophile. What
are you talking about? Why are you
calling out Chris Tyson for Lollipop?"
>> Aiden became a Leo Convoy Alog because
he met a girl online who was wronged by
him and made it his entire [__]
personality. That's why.
>> And now here now, Msizkip is talking
about why the stream awards failed.
>> Gaining what I have. Like I don't care
to grow too much.
>> You know what's crazy? His whole life
philosophy comes from Tony Stark during
Endgame. Keep what we have and get back
what we lost. Like that's literally
Bolex's whole future is designed by Tony
Stark in Avengers Endgame.
Do you remember when Onision used
Turboax and tried to expose the
government for like threat like I guess
like auditing him or something because
he didn't fill out the forms correctly?
>> Not good.
>> And everyone's like why dude? He's like
a huge YouTuber making millions of
dollars and he couldn't hire an account.
He was too [__] cheap to hire an
accountant and try and then like just
tried to freeball it, dude on like on
his own [__]
>> It'd be the same. It's
>> This reminds me of like the Family Guy
[__] where uh Mr. Peterships Mr. It's
like Peter's making me do A A BIG BANG
THEORY watch party with all the guys in
the office. Now I do them regardless cuz
the show is really funny. [laughter]
>> He now claims that he has changed his
content, no longer watches full videos
on stream, but I hardly see how that
would save him if some latigious freak
like Ethan or Dark Viper determined that
he did a bad reaction to one of their
videos. Denim's losing this case could
very well provide a legal precedent that
could be used against Aorio's style of
reaction. That reason alone should deter
him from blatantly supporting Ethan's
attempts to ruin free speech on the
internet. Nicholas has also supported
Ethan in the blatant lies that he has
perpetrated against Denims. Back in the
spring, Ethan used an edited and
filtered video of Denim's chat to push
the narrative that her entire community
in live chat were calling for Ethan to
lose.
>> This is a great point, great point
coming up here.
>> Amazing point I discussed on stream with
Ogie once. chat to push the narrative
that her entire community in live chat
were calling for Ethan to lose his kids
and for someone to call CPS on him.
>> It was apparently
>> No, I think this is love.
>> This guy's a virgin. Is this
>> every comment? I believe this is a live
feed of the chat. This isn't edited.
>> What about the top right? I I thought
>> you're telling me this guy gets no
[__]
>> I think when you full screen it. No,
this is an edit. It's a cutout of the
full chat that's just enlarged there
over the screen. Yeah.
>> Here are the first and last frames of
the video that he played. I searched for
the top and the bottom messages in my
Chatterino history. The first one is
line 14,472.
The second is 15,428
and they're 5 minutes apart. That's 956
messages in 5 minutes.
>> So, this all just a great all just a
great point. Great rebuttal from Denims
here. Only 6.8% of the chat and half the
[__] comments aren't even actually
[__] legit. He showed 65 messages
which is less than 7% of the messages
from that time period.
>> Yo, thank you Sonia for the five gifted
meshes. Huge appreciated. Thank you so
much. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Sonia. Thank you.
Huge appreciated.
Nick nodded his head and pushed this
narrative, ultimately placing
responsibility on Dennis for the CPS
call. a statement about it and said that
she does not condone calling CPS.
>> So, we're talking about CPS. One, I
don't condone.
>> Yeah. It doesn't mean she's not
partially responsible for this occurring
by signal boosting this on a huge
[__] platform when you're astroturf
by Hassan Per who's using
>> Well, this is the thing is it's it's a
matter of um can't and won't, right?
Nick can't Dioro can't Fuentes won't.
Thank you for the $5. [__] bad
empanada as an attack dog.
>> Now, I can criticize Denims for not
pushing back hard enough on Bad Empanada
in this reaction, but ultimately I do
not place responsibility for the CPS
call on Denims. There's no evidence
showing that she herself called CPS and
she multiple times stated that she
disavows calling CPS on Ethan. As of
December 26th, 2025, Nicholas
>> Nick Fuentes doesn't get any gash and
you worship him.
>> Also, please don't say gash again. Okay,
that's just one I can't do. Thank you.
Bill abides by the principle that you
are not responsible for every member of
your audience, even if someone does an
unhinged action.
>> I'm sorry. You can't police this. You
cannot police an audience. The only time
you're responsible for your audience is
if you spread misinformation that causes
them to go and harass somebody who
didn't deserve it. Like if you spread a
false rape allegation of some kind and
your audience goes and clowns that
person,
>> Dash and Slick go hard. If you're really
trying to be vulgar,
>> your fault you generally the only time
you're responsible for your audience is
if you spread misinformation that causes
them to go and harass somebody who
didn't deserve it.
>> Like if you spread a false rape
allegation of some kind and your
audience goes and clowns that person,
that is your fault. you have given them
bad information, they have gone and
acted on that stuff.
>> Um, and now,
>> but the expectation that you can prevent
crazy people from doing crazy [__] that
are statistically going,
>> "Oh, he's saying this now. It's like,
dude, this is obscene, dude. Ethan
literally just says [__] whatever
about these people
>> to be watching you is absolutely [__]
insane. The only solution to that is
never criticizing anybody ever again
online and living in a padded cell." So,
even if the CPS call came from one crazy
denim viewer, she's not ultimately
responsible for it. While she didn't
have perfect coverage of the bad
empanada video, that doesn't make it
right to lie about her and spread
deceptively edited clips to paint her as
responsible for the CPS lie. Nick
refused to properly engage with this
criticism on multiple occasions,
originally stating on Twitter that the
only editing done to this clip was
simply enlarging the chat on screen to
make it easier to read, handwaving it
away as a snarker narrative and claiming
that there was no context manipulation
at all, despite again only displaying a
heavily filtered selection of chat
messages. On stream, the context of this
clip came up again, and this time, Nick
didn't even give a take or opinion of
any kind. He just kind of trailed off
and said that the objectively correct
narrative behind the context of this
clip was stupid and he found it funny.
Um, and and and and no, Ethan, you don't
understand. You manipulated it. You
manipulated it by
>> This clip is literally the
absolute most [__] clip ever. This
is like so embarrassing that he did
this.
>> Said that the objectively correct
narrative behind the context of this
clip was stupid and he found it funny.
>> Um, and and and no, Ethan, you don't
understand. You manipulated it. You
manipulated it by showing messages on
the screen alongside [__] It's so
stupid, dude. The narrative behind that
video is so funny to me.
>> Again, another instance of Nicholas not
engaging in criticism when he knows that
he's wrong. Essentially just downplaying
potential criticism for Ethan by
handwaving the context away. Nick failed
to address this again when he reacted to
Idubbbz's content deputy on Ethan Klein,
stating that he knows that the chat was
edited, but it was just the timing of
[music] the chat on stream that was
changed and all of the messages were
real and in context. It's one chat on
one stream at different points
>> to make it seem like someone is
coordinating an attack on you.
>> Love [snorts] made a a good point. You
said, "Is this
>> someone is literally coordinating an
attack on him?" AB,
[laughter]
>> absolutely. Unequivocally. And then he
plays the clip where Ethan explicitly
tells you, okay, that they clipped the
chat and it's like a [__] cutout.
>> It's like the most blatant lying of all
time. Like,
how do you deal with people like this
truly that will just go out there and
lie and dodge their entire like any
criticism and just lie to their audience
night after night?
>> Yeah, they're different, I think.
>> Yeah.
>> And like it's it's it's directly
explained to you in the stream what
exactly this is. Like love literally
says it's not timed the same way.
>> It's not timed the same way. Like the
context is in the clip. It's not
[__] Denims has confirmed in her
own video that those messages did come
from her chat. There was never any
contesting of the legitimacy of these
messages. The issue is that this is a
tiny percentage of the total chat
messages sent during this time and
creators like Ethan and Nick lied to
portray it as the sentiment of Denim's
entire chat. There's only one other
instance I could find of Nick addressing
this lie after this. Mean's response to
the content deputy, he outright admitted
that this clip was edited and showed
only a small percentage of Denim's total
chat. Nick conveniently did not engage
with this because he would have to take
an L and instead just started loudly
reading his chat and didn't pay
attention to what Ethan was saying.
>> Oh, dude. This is funny as well, man.
This shit's funny, too.
>> So, at first I made that mistake. I
genuinely thought
>> I want to point out that Froggen is more
mature and empathetic than Ian. She
said, uh, I don't know. It depends.
>> The guy
soon after
>> I will say though, yeah, I didn't really
see Frogan engage with that. It was more
like
>> he's just avoiding it like crazy. It's
so [__] funny.
>> A W there. But it might just be because
she wasn't watched enough to
>> he's such an avoidant little rat to a
remembermber 2016 tangent before going
back to defending Ethan for spreading
this lie incorrectly stating that he
showed the full context of Denim's chat
in the original clip.
>> The shameless lie that is immediately
explained even in the clip that Ian
shows. Maybe Nick did just accidentally
speak over the context of these lies.
Push, but I believe that he still needs
to expressly address these claims and
acknowledge that he pushed clips out of
context. He'll get right on that
and his orbiters.
>> Ultimately, he'll he'll get right on
correcting that total [__] insane lie
that he spread repeatedly. And I'm sure
he'll take full accountability for it.
He'll say, you know, I was wrong. That's
actually a pretty significant part of
Ethan's claims about denims. And uh I've
actually lied about that several times
or I've been wrong about that several
times. I I really [__] that up, guys.
Guys, you should really question what
what Ethan's saying about some of this
stuff because that's not good that even
I fell for that for so long.
>> 5 has seen the erosion of principles
from Nick regarding Ethan Klein. He went
from one of his most prolific critics to
excusing many of the same behaviors that
he once criticized Ethan for. Nick has
become Ethan's largest orbiter and will
even outright lie about other creators
to benefit Ethan and profit from the
situation. There's now so much money and
clout tied up in the situation that
actively taking a fair and balanced
position would severely impact Nick's
revenue stream. It is simply not as
profitable or popular to take a nuanced
position on these controversial topics.
Nick has seen tremendous success in 2025
by becoming a climb propagandist. He
went from averaging close to 1,000 to
averaging around four or 5,000
concurrent viewers. But in order to do
that, he had to sacrifice both his
credibility and long-standing
principles.
My biggest nonH3H3 criticisms of Nick
are what I refer to as his Cabal
mindset. basically his reluctance to
properly criticize his close friends and
a sudden desire to shield and isolate
himself from nearly all criticism. This
can mainly be seen in his coverage of
the commentator Willie Max show
throughout the course of the year.
Willie Max show received a lot of
criticism throughout the first half of
the year for how many feel mishandled
his coverage on Destiny's criminal
allegations.
>> I think I should be fine to pull this
up.
>> All right.
>> Cops in this [__] country did
>> okay. Wait, we'll tune into this in a
bit. We'll tune into this. Dude, do you
want to know what they did? They made a
[__] panel over who could use the
slur. Uh, it's the the [__] it's it's
it's like the the C word for [__]
Muslims. I'm not going to whatever. But
they did a panel over who could [__]
say it.
>> But we are going to tier list them and
we're going to need your help.
>> Sorry. Yeah. He thinks it's like
raccoon, you know? He thinks it's like
that one
>> to discuss and figure out who can say
habibi and who can't.
>> We have tiers. We have Arab, Arabcoded.
They ask permission to say habibi, you
know, like like you got like a white guy
is like, "Can I say it? Is it a slur?"
Okay. You know what I'm saying? And then
you have thinks it's a slur where it's
like a white person that really they're
like, "No, I'm not going to say that.
I'm so sorry."
>> I think they should run this panel back
next year, but with the hard R. Put up
four.
>> So like he's on here like he can pretend
like he's not cheerleading the sponsor
[__] but he's like on there running the
same point, not having a [__] clue
what he's talking about. Just yet
another time where Nick's oh I I don't
want to know anything about the Middle
East. Just a bunch of brown people
fighting over rocks. Yet another time
where it just like makes him look
totally [__] even when he's just
trying to talk about the drama because
it's like how can you possibly have a
criticism of this if you don't
understand what the word is and what the
context of it is.
Like he just hears those jokes being
made and takes as given that it's a
slur. No, they're joking about the fact
it's not a slur, bro. It's like not a
slur. It's just like a
what is it ter term of endearment
like you know it's like friend dude
buddy
pal
homie
it's used that way and yes obviously if
a white person used it just out of
nowhere it would
it come off a bit weird cuz it's it's
quite a you know specific
um you know like ethnic reason or
whatever thing, but it's not a slur.
It's not like there's some rule against
it. It's not like it there's like a
you can't use it if you're white. Whites
do and it's cringe. Yeah, exactly. It's
it'd be like a little bit cringe white
person, but it's not like the n word.
It's not like Uncle Tom or some [__]
like that. Like you say it to a an Arab
and they freak the [__] out of you.
That's it's [laughter] just not what the
case is. So he's like cheerleading this
[__] point about this stupid [__]
tier list thinking this is like a
full-blown slur like this is actual
racial abuse. Black guys and Destiny to
figure it out. I show speed Kaisen KSI
Deji and Destiny that's the panel I'd
run chat. They did this at Twitchcon
dude.
>> Wait one legal situation. Two of the
main critics of Willie were the queen.
These two have spent extensive time
covering and researching every aspect of
the Destiny allegations. So when Willie
Mack put out what they believed was a
poorly researched video, they were quick
to hop on a call with him and debate
over the issues they had with his
coverage. Nick took great issue with
this treatment of Willie and even
decided to debate Auggie RFC over his
treatment. Nick was clearly very
bothered about how Willie was treated in
this call, constantly making passive
aggressive remarks and not fully
understanding the points they were
making in this debate.
>> Well, you talked about Destiny tonight.
Have you talked about all the JTalk
approved talking points? Have you gone
through the list?
>> What are the Jtock approved talking
points?
>> I don't know. I didn't pay attention to
them. But if you didn't include them,
you're sweeping.
>> The criticism against Willie Mac show
is, you know, all dismissible. In fact,
I agree with a lot of it, honestly.
>> Which criticism in particular? Cuz it
was like I thought the Queen one was a
little stupid, but then I heard the
Kelly Jean one and then I thought it was
really stupid. And then I heard the
Jtock one and then I thought it was
completely I I thought it was
indefensible. You think that all the
streamer people are gay?
>> I thought the video Well, let me
elaborate on my point. I thought so.
Okay,
>> I like Nick's Discord messages saying he
should stream during Chud's time slot to
really clean clean up. Yeah, so Nick and
Tommy and all these retards obviously
had all these conversations behind the
scenes about cutting people off and
being able to like nuke his viewership
and they feel like Chud, you know, being
on like whatever he is 700 D every day
now is like total total victory. like
them cutting him off as I totally raped
him and all this [__] So Nick seems to
be under some kind of uh delusion
that you know saying things like that is
going to knock Chud back in line or
assert himself over a broader audience
in some way
when really all it is is him sucking
himself off to a tiny little cult of
mentally ill trans people in his in his
discord.
Uh he doesn't seem to realize
Chad is totally quiet quitting
and has no fight in him.
I literally I will stream about this
guy, talk about this guy, pointing out
how much of a disgusting, dishonest
[__] [__] he is endlessly. I will
do it week after week. I don't care if
I'm on
15 viewers doing it, 50 viewers doing
it, or 500 viewers doing it.
I will sit here and I and I will be on
500 viewers doing it. At least, you
know, I say at least, we're on 450 right
now, but you know, around there. You
know what I'm saying? I I will be there
because people want to see it because
there is a growing audience that want
the fight because Chud doesn't have I
understand Chud doesn't have the fight.
Ch does not have the fight. And I've
seen that. I see that in in his eyes in
his dead eyes after the after he
received head trauma from a table while
drunk.
Thank you for the 10 memberships.
Godspeed. That's hugely appreciated.
Thank you so much.
But there are people like Tony
Hencliffe, you know, hungry like the
wolf. hungry like the wolf. Who will sit
there, who will talk about you every
[__] week, who don't care if you've
got a annoying ass [__] wine mom
audience that you inherited. An audience
that you used to hate, that you said
were awful in every single way that you
now inherited as your own. the the
willpower through it. But I will sit
here understanding that you are a
cowardly, pathetic, dishonest rodent who
does feel deeply insecure about the
amount of respect he feels online, who
does take very seriously his credibility
and self-image online and will literally
spend every week
sitting here picking it apart, doing
whatever I need to, talking to whichever
[__] video essaist and helping with
our research that I need to to make sure
everyone knows exactly the ways ways in
which you're a disgusting, spineless,
dishonest, low life and you can cope and
pretend it's about, oh, people are
pocket watching me. People are pocket.
They don't like I got my Roelly like
Ethan. I got my Roi like Ethan.
It's not about the money. It's about
making sure that you know and everyone
around you knows and everyone that
watches you knows you're a disgusting
[__] low life.
To briefly summarize, Quimman and Jtock
were critical of Willie Mack for priding
himself on talking to everyone involved
in the Destiny situation, but not
speaking to some of his main victims and
not going in depth enough on the main
allegations himself. He spent half of
the video talking about how President
Sunday and Beckett mishandled the
release of the Pixie story instead of
nailing Destiny down with better
research talking points. For months,
Nick played up the treatment that Willie
received from this community, pretending
as if he was beaten and raped live or
something. Nick kept making the same
lame talking point about Will. Yo, thank
you very much for the five gifted.
Thank you so much. Thank you. [music]
Huge appreciate it. Thank you. [bell]
Being too much of a normie to make good
content. He's just a regular guy who
doesn't have time to worry about all
this online stuff.
>> People go crazy when I say Willy's not
like internet people. He's not
terminally online. He's just like some
[__] guy who makes commentary videos.
And I don't think it's ever been more
obvious than like right now in this
conversation. Ignore him going 15
replies deep with morale on Twitter or
cutting off his connections with chud
logic over a minor joke at his expense.
He's just a normie that doesn't have
time to properly research his videos.
Nick went as far as calling this
criticism a gross harassment campaign
against Willy Mac instead of what it
really was. Criticism of a large creator
who uploads poorly researched videos
that routinely get information wrong on
complex topics. really has been like a
[__] uh target of like a crazy
harassment campaign from like every
other person online it feels like
because he's a normal guy who has normal
guy taste
>> and you know what it is it's even about
more than Nick being a low life but you
need real vision for that okay and I
can't spell it out to you it's about the
bigger picture and you need real vision
for that
>> I don't even want to say surface level
but great introductory videos for
average people to watch on terminally
online internet drama. Um, and there's
just like this barrage of hatred this
guy gets for like absolutely no reason
because he gets like minor things wrong
in videos.
Apparently like the worst content ever.
>> Actually, let's hear what Nick has to
say about calling video criticism
harassment.
>> Oh, you've misreported a story and
gotten criticized for it. Hm. Time to
pull the free speech card. Why? Why is
it harassment to not like a YouTube
video? Why are you guys so [__]
pathetic? Nick has hung on to this idea
that the anti- Destiny community, as he
calls them, are so unhinged for the ways
that they demanded that he cover Destiny
that it is unreasonable to ever hear
them out or respond to any of their
valid criticisms. He used this treatment
as an excuse to distance himself from
the Quean and Jtock communities that he
once collaborated with. This distancing
essentially led to Nick entering his own
fortress arc of sorts and no longer
participating in confrontational content
or debates of any kind. Throughout 2024,
in the beginning of 2025, Nick had
occasionally collaborated with Quean and
would even sometimes raid into his
streams.
>> I'm gonna send you to Quean. Somebody
reached out to me and they're like, "You
should stop going to Quean because
[laughter] Queeman hates you, Nicholas
Dioro." Queen hates
>> I didn't hate this guy back then. I
didn't hate this guy back then.
>> That hates you and you're like a cuck
for raiding him. It's like I like
Queman. Quan is friends with me. Um
[laughter]
I I I don't care that he disagrees with
me on certain things. I have absolutely
no problem that that is happening. Uh I
I think that if you're more bent up
about it than me, you probably wouldn't
be able to do very well in my position.
You probably shouldn't really give me
advice to you.
>> How to handle my friends.
>> Now, not interacting or acknowledging
this community is Nick's main strategic
priority. When Nick cut off his
friendship with Aiden underground over a
minor DM leak that wasn't even Aiden's
fault, Nick went as far as saying, "My
chief concern above my friendship with
Aiden, yes, is that I'm not forced to
address this [__] to my stream or
Discord chat. This is incredibly
weak-minded behavior from someone who
criticizes others for a living. I have a
general principle that if you dish out
criticism, you should be at the bare
minimum willing to take equal criticism
in some way. And also, I could see if
Quimman was some absolutely insane
Spurge with a minimum.
>> People were like, you know, [laughter]
why do people enjoy this civil cameo so
much? Why do people enjoy the fact that
this junk draw used so much?
>> Like Mr. Sen. But Queenman is a creator
that Nick propped up through 2024 and
early 2025. During the Mudahar, Mama
Max, and Boax dramas, he agreed with
Quean's criticisms and even collaborated
with him on some occasions. But now that
Quean has criticisms of Nick and his
terrible H3H3 coverage, he writes him
off as some sort of obsessive Destiny
antifan, blocks him on all social media,
and refuses to address him. Nick's
sweeping and isolation peaked over the
summer when he outright refused to cover
Willie Mack's slanderous video, Hassan
and his criminal friend docks and try to
ruin my wedding. In this video, Willie
outright lied about Quean and JTOK
running doxing communities and harboring
audience members who doxed Willie and
propagated information about his
upcoming wedding on Kiwi Farms. If you
want to see more in-depth coverage of
this awful video, back in August, I
posted a video that fully broke down my
issues with it. To briefly summarize,
Willie presented no evidence at all to
back up these claims, and it was even
revealed that this information was given
to him directly by Destiny. At the time,
Destiny was trying to frame JTO and
Quean as doxers. This was so he could
have justification to dox them and their
communities as some sort of self-defense
doxing.
>> I will dox if I have the opportunity to
doobie [__] is getting posted if I get
it my hands on it 100%. For Anna like I
legitimately
>> dy what is doobie sin
>> the being in the in cahoots these
[__] weirdo a loggers that are
obsessively talking about me talking
about me to every other [__] person
and doing this weird pressure.
>> Oh yeah. I saw some clip while I was at
Aiden's hotel the other day on my phone
of Destiny like literally listing out
like every [__] [__] just like
talking about Kathy for like five
[__] minutes.
So, bro, what how are you spending your
time? And he was like crying cuz I
pulled up that stream of
Kinda. I should face cam on and I just
said whose auntie is this? Whose auntie
is this? Then moved on. All right.
That's so that's so weird. This guy's so
weird and going after it looks so so
personal cuz I said whose auntie is this
and then moved on. It's so weird. So
weird. He's such a queer, bro. It's
literally [__] insane.
In the background, anybody that's part
of like those communities in my mind is
all homos to me.
>> Willie being the [__] that he is played
right into this narrative by doing no
factchecking and just running with
Destiny's talking points. When members
of the commentary community had serious
issues with this video, making such bold
claims and presenting literally zero
evidence, Nick did very briefly address
this on stream. He talked about it for 3
minutes total before he claimed that it
was gay interpersonal community drama
and only spoke about the video one other
time in his Discord. Now, uh why about
probably six of you are in the stream, I
just wanted to briefly talk about this
Willie Max show drama. Uh I I made it
pretty clear that I didn't really want
to do the interpersonal drama [__] a
couple of weeks ago. And up until this
point, I've probably done as much of
that as I possibly could. I'll just say
I told Willie Machro that he should just
drop this and he should stop um
[laughter] he should just leave. He
should just stop fighting with these
people. And in retaliation, a video came
out talking all about these people. So,
at that point, there's really not much I
can say or do. I I I gave him my
opinion. Um [laughter]
he did the opposite. So now I think that
him and Auggie are gonna fight a lot.
And I I'm I'm rooting for uh you to get
as much content as you want out of it.
And at this point, my understanding of
how this is going to move forward from
here is I think that everyone's just
going to be awful. [laughter] It doesn't
really seem like anybody is moving into
this discussion looking to have a um a
beautiful productive dialogue. It just
seems like from here everybody's going
to start sideswiping each other.
>> Uh listen, I've had to put multiple
friends down.
Oh, here we go. Here's the card every
summer to watch Nicholas Dioro come
through and assassinate.
>> Is it putting putting your friend down
to say, "Yeah, this video is really
bad." And you know, you should probably
like think about correcting it.
That's actually killing someone, guys.
That's killing someone. You're forcing
him to kill his friend right now because
you said, "Hey, you should cover this
video like you would cover any other
video from this content creator and just
engage like remotely critically.
another friend so you can tell me all
for the next six months about what a
huge piece of [__] backstabber I am up
until the point where the next friend
says two words out of line and all of a
sudden it's banging down the door to go
make me talk about it again. I think the
commentary community can probably handle
this one on their own. [laughter]
I wish you both luck in your forever
war. Nick has outright admitted in his
Discord that this video was bad, but
never acknowledged that Willie outright
lied in his coverage and has not made
any effort to retract his claims or
provide proof. Nick has continued to
support Willie since the release of this
video. He's watched his Klein propaganda
videos on stream and endorse several
pieces of his content. Any other
commentator would be torn to shreds for
releasing a video like this, but because
Willie is in Nick's inroup, he gets a
pass and will never be properly pressed
for this video. Nick was always the guy
who was willing to call it his friends
and even burn bridges when he felt like
someone was [__] up to a serious
degree. Nick spent basically all of 2023
and 2024 ripping into people like
Tipster and Bolex. So, what exactly did
Tipster and Bolex do compared to Willie?
Bolex lied to Nick personally about his
mental health diagnosis and publicly
lied about Nick running the Content Cop
Twitter page. He's a total loser who
deserves to be called out for this
behavior. But I would still say this is
less egregious than Willie lying because
commentators like Nick called out these
lies. I'm receiving reports that Aiden
is doing like really embarrassing um
like autistic ling
where he's he's saying that oh Hellbent
was under no obligation to help me do
anything
as if you shouldn't you know be sort of
grateful even if someone go does
something you didn't necessarily ask
them to do because he thinks it makes
him seem like a cool like you know cold
like oh I just see things logically It's
like very obvious that that's how he
sees himself and how he wants to be
perceived.
Very embarrassing, very shameful.
>> And Bob is a widely mocked figure that
nobody takes seriously. Tipster was too
eager to defend the wrong people and
ended up making poor defenses for
Lollcon content mult.
>> But even Patrick Baitman would fake it.
Even Patrick Baitman would fake it to be
manipulative. That's the thing.
But no, Aiden Aiden is just like a
[__] petulant child. I don't think
Tipster's pro Lolli. He just offended
like three people who were involved in
Loi controversies within a one-year time
frame, and it ended up looking very
suspicious. In terms of commentary, he
publicly cut ties with the community and
would very performatively talk about how
toxic everybody was. It was very well
within his right to leave, but he did so
in a very obnoxious and unsuccessful
way. In reality, as Tommy Cy describes
it, Nick hated Tipster so much because
he broke his heart by leaving the
community the way that he did. probably
less Nick than any of them.
And I think Nick [__] targeted you
four years for because you broke his
[__] heart. And he's not going to say
that, but I will. If Nick was still
willing to cut off Tipster and Bolex for
these misdeeds, you would assume that he
did not actively prop up and promote a
creator who still has a video on his
channel with over 200,000 views where he
is smearing the reputations of several
small creators. As of December 2025,
Nick is still watching Willy's H3H3 slop
videos on stream and sending people to
check out his channel, where they can
easily find this video that is full of
lies and misinformation. Nick has also
historically been willing to call out
commentary creators who have made
terrible videos that are either full of
lies or blatantly dishonest, even those
that he considered friends. Nick entered
a yearslong feud with technicals over
his awful coverage of the Zero situation
in which he lied and mischaracterized
the narrative surrounding a pedophile
just to win a personal feud over his
enemies. Before this, these two were
friends, frequently collaborating on
videos and appearing on streams
together. While I do have serious issues
with Nick's coverage of Zaptai that I
might get into another time, I do
believe that he was generally in the
right to call out the sweeping for Zero.
And I do believe that Zero was much
worse than Zapi. Nick also spent a large
portion of 2024 calling out King of
Nothing for slandering Ethan Klein.
>> Take take a stance on which Peter was
worse. Take a stance on which was worse.
of his videos, even going as far as
saying the video was borderline
defamation and saying that anything less
than a full video removal should be
kindly ignored and remembered upon King
of Nothing.
>> If not, it seems Lom isn't really your
guy, but Hayden the party.
>> I think it'd be awesome if Lom came. I
don't think Lom would come to the UK
though. I thought his girlfriend
wouldn't let me either. Kaija Kais
upload King of Nothing at least tried to
show evidence of Ethan Klein being an
NFT scammer despite how poor that
evidence actually was. Willie Mack never
showed any evidence of Queenman or JTOK
running docing communities and is a
significantly larger creator, making it
much more difficult for these smaller
channels to correct the record about how
Willie was lying. So, in the past, Nick
would proudly jump in to call out and
heavily criticize.
>> You're so gay it makes me sick like
constantly. How am I being gay? How am I
being gay? Creators. Nick has always
made a big deal about self-p policing
your community to root out bad actors.
>> Yeah. I mean, the perfect place to hang
out if you want to be never questioned
on anything, right, is to hang out in a
place that doesn't self police. And
Hassan's community and that sector of
like far-left tanky adjacent people,
there's no self-p policing because they
can't find anyone who wants to like like
nobody wants to make content with them.
They're all kind of trapped in their own
little
comfortable lying to you. But when one
of his friends decide to put out a
slanderous hit piece, Nick declares the
drama too gay and interpersonal and
refuses to properly engage with it. I'm
not even saying that Nick needs to
completely cut off and end his
friendship with Willie. But it should be
the expectation in the commentary space
that if a large creator makes a very
poor video, other creators should be
willing to call out and publicly correct
the record, especially if this creator
is someone that you constantly promote
and associate with. It seems that in his
year-long quest to become an H3H3
orbiter, Nick has forgotten these
standards and principles that he once
had.
2025 has seen a great many changes for
Nick. It has seen him abandon most of
his principles to chase a very lucrative
new audience that he will gladly push
straight up lies for. Nick no longer
cares about the quality of his coverage,
self-pleasing his community, or
listening to criticism of any kind.
Instead, he would rather rake in
tremendous amounts of money and try to
rock the boat as minimally as possible.
I for one hope that in 2026 the general
audience will start to see the lies that
the clients and their orbiters have
pushed and will be more acceptable to
have a nuanced position on the
neverending war between Ethan Hassan and
Destiny. Hopefully in the new year Nick
can reevaluate some of his principles
and actually address some of the major
criticisms have been levied against him.
But with just how successful his
coverage has been, that ultimately seems
unlikely. Thank you to anyone who
watched this all the way through. Your
support means a lot. Make sure to
subscribe, leave a like, and follow me
on Twitter or Instagram. My accounts are
on the screen. or if you want to join my
discord that's linked below.
>> Wow, what a great video from Junk Draw
there.